-They love you!
-Aw, I love you, guys.
-We love you. Welcome to the --
I want to say
welcome back to the show
because you actually made
your late-night debut
on our show
with "Drivers License."
-"Drivers License." Yep.
-But we never chatted.
-I know.
I'm so happy to be here.
I'm such a fan of the show.
Growing up, I used to watch it
every night with my parents.
I'm such a huge fan,
so it's an honor to be here.
You actually -- I met you,
um, maybe three year--
You wouldn't have remembered.
It was -- It was so long ago.
-What do you mean,
I wouldn't remember?
-It was in a group of people,
but there was a group of people,
and they were like,
"Hey, hey, hey."
And you actually went up to
my mom and you gave her a hug.
And it is her bragging rights
for the rest of her life.
She loves you so much.
-Oh, my gosh.
-She sends her regards and she
says, "Thank you for the hug."
-Hi, Mom! Hi! Yeah.
Uh, I follow you
on the socials, and I --
You're a great fellow,
by the way,
if you like the social media.
But I noticed that
you don't follow anyone back.
-Oh. I'm sorry.
If I was following one person,
it'd be you, though, I hope.
-Thank you. Oh, yeah.
Really, though...
-Ah, [bleep].
-Any reason why?
[ Laughter ]
-No, you know,
I try to follow zero people
because it helps me
be off of my phone,
you know,
off of social media.
But I had this very embarrassing
encounter once
where I was stalking my ex,
as one does.
Sue me. Sorry.
And, um --
And I accidentally followed him
because I was stalking him, and
I was just following one person,
so it was super obvious
that I was following him.
And my friend ran into my room
and was like, "Oh, my God!
Did you mean to follow him?
Like, unfollow him!"
And I went
and I grabbed my phone.
I'm like,
"Oh, shoot! Oh, my God!"
And I went to open
the Instagram app.
And the second that I opened
the app, my phone died.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Couldn't find the charger.
So I was just following
my ex for a while.
-Did it come out
that you were --
Yeah, and people were like,
"Oh, my gosh! She's hacked!"
And I'm like, "Yeah, you guys.
Be safe." Like...
[ Laughter ]
"Get your two-factor
authentication, you guys."
-You weren't hacked it all.
You did it yourself.
-Yeah. Sorry.
-Oh, my gosh. Alright.
So now -- But you don't make
that mistake again.
-No, no. I have a Finsta now,
so I'm safe.
-You have a finsta.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you have a Finsta, Jimmy.
-I need a Finsta.
-Yeah. You need a Finsta.
-A fake Instagram.
-Fake Instagram. Yeah.
So you can just lurk
and be curious.
-Yeah. And like things
and look at things and...
Wait. I'm totally getting
a Finsta this week.
-Yeah. Okay.
-Alright. Thank you.
I appreciate it.
I want to talk to you.
I have so many things
to talk to you about.
First of all,
congratulations on "GUTS."
-Thank you.
-Uh, this is unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Went right to number one
when it released.
And then you got nominated
just now for six Grammys.
Uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You have three Grammys on your
shelf already from "Sour,"
but how does it feel
to be nominated for six?
I mean, you're part of this --
This is your year now.
-It's so surreal.
I actually can't believe it.
I feel like
the luckiest girl alive.
I used to go
to the Grammy Museum
all the time when I was younger,
and, actually,
my mom and I used to, like,
make ballots for the Grammys,
like, when the Grammys
were on TV.
When I was like 12, I'd be like,
"I think this album
is going to win."
And, like, we'd do --
place bets and stuff.
-No way!
-So it's a super-big deal.
Yeah, it's just --
it's such an honor
to be included in a group
with all these artists
that I just am so inspired by.
-You more than
hold your own, bud.
And now here we go.
This "Hunger Games" soundtrack.
The new song is called
"Can't Catch Me Now."
What's it like writing a song
for a movie or, like --
Because you're not --
This, you write
your songs for you.
-Yeah, that's like my diary,
but this was a totally
different experience for me
as a songwriter.
It was so much fun.
I'm such a big fan
of all things "Hunger Games,"
and I love the soundtracks,
and so when they asked
if I wanted to write it,
I was so stoked.
And I went in
and watched the movie
and was really inspired by
the main character, Lucy Gray.
Um, and so it was super-fun
to get to write a song
through her eyes.
It was definitely a big stretch
for me as a songwriter.
It was really fun.
-Well, February is gonna
be a giant month for you
because you have the Grammys,
you turn 21, by the way.
-Yeah.
-Happy birthday.
Happy early birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm very excited
about that one.
-And you're kicking off
your "GUTS" world tour.
This is what everyone's
talking about
and trying to get tickets for.
I mean, this is wild.
You're gonna play
all these giant arenas.
-Yeah.
-Do you get nervous
when you do these giant gigs?
-Oh, man. So nervous.
I get super nervous. Yeah.
I saw you at the Jingle Ball
last week, and I was like --
And you were so kind of calm...
-Yeah.
-...to be performing for,
you know, 20,000, 30,000 people.
-Yeah, you know, it's different.
I feel like playing
your own show is a lot more fun
because there's just so many
people in the audience,
and sometimes they know
the lyrics, too,
so if you, like, forget a lyric,
you're like,
"Throw it to the crowd!"
-Yeah, yeah.
Is there a song you're psyched
to play live?
-Ooh, um, I'm really excited.
I wrote this song called
"All-American Bitch"
that I really like.
-Yeah. I love that one.
-Yeah, so,
it's super-fun and rowdy,
and I just hope people
can, like,
scream and dance and go crazy.
-Yeah!
Guys, get prepared to sing.
Yeah, yeah.
Uh, we found something online
that I wanted
to ask you about.
There's a -- There's a thing
that said that you once
wrote an original Christmas song
when you were 5.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Do you remember doing this?
-Start 'em young. I don't even
remember. No, I don't.
But, yeah, I know
what you're talking about.
-It was called "The Bels"
or something like that.
The album cover's online.
-Oh! Look at that.
-Yeah.
-B-E-L-S.
-Close. Very close.
-Yeah.
You know, I couldn't write,
but it didn't stop me
from writing a song.
-Yeah. No.
I like the "Bels" with one L.
Why not?
-Yeah.
-What was it about?
Do you remember the song at all?
What was it about?
-Oh, I think it's like, um --
I think it's about, like,
waiting for Santa,
like, waiting to hear,
like, bells or something.
-Five years old.
-Yeah.
-I wish we had it, but --
Actually we do.
-Oh.
-We found a copy of it.
And thanks, Mom.
Here's the original song,
"The Bels,"
a snippet from
5-year-old Olivia Rodriguez.
-Man, man.
-♪ Ho, ho, ho, ho ♪
♪ Wait for the bells ♪
[ Laughs ]
♪ When you hear them ♪
♪ Put the ornaments
on the tree ♪
♪ Ho, ho, ho, ho ♪
♪ Wait for the bells ♪
♪ Wait for the bells
on Santa's sleigh to ring ♪
♪ Ho, ho, ho, ho ♪
-Oh!
♪ Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like that. That's a jam.
-Man.
-You wrote a jam at 5 years old.
-Thanks. Sheesh. Wow.
-Olivia, you kind of, like,
manifested this career, which...
-I suppose so.
I mean, I was writing songs,
like, at such an early age.
Yeah, I've always been into it.
-And you had a pop --
a pop-star themed birthday party
when you were 6.
-Yes. I did, I did.
-And your mom also
gave us a photo of this.
-Oh, wow.
Walk down memory lane today.
-She's the b--
I'm glad I hugged her that day.
She's totally writing
this whole interview for me.
This is you
on your 6th birthday,
a pop-star themed party.
-Oh, man!
-And you even had, like,
a play-- like, a set list.
-Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
I really manifested this hard.
Yeah. There was not an audience.
No one was watching.
But I just had all of my,
like, kindergarten friends,
and we were just singing,
like, the Jonas Brothers.
We were really into it.
-Isn't that fantastic?
-Yeah.
-And now this weekend,
you're going to be musical
guest on "Saturday Night Live."
-Ahh!
-I mean, look at you, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-I think the last time
you actually did perform
"Saturday Night Live," right?
-Yeah, I did.
It was actually
my second time performing ever,
like, my own songs
in front of --
Besides that.
I mean, that doesn't count.
-Yeah. No. Yeah.
"The Bels." Of course.
-"The Bels." Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, but, yeah,
I'm really excited.
The first time I ever did it --
-Do you like the pressure?
I mean, do you like to go in
like, "Yeah, go ahead,
I'll do the Super Bowl,
give it to me, let's go"?
It's like, "Why not?"
And just go for it.
-I get really nervous.
-You do?
-It's just -- It's live-live.
I mean, you know.
Do you have any tips for me?
You're a --
-No. Just enjoy it.
-Yeah?
-Yeah. That's it.
I love doing live.
I love a live audience.
Nothing like it.
I mean, it's the best.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They tell you --
You feed off the energy.
-Yeah.
-You're going to crush it.
I can't wait to watch.
Olivia Rodrigo, everybody.
"Can't Catch Me Now" is out now.
Olivia and I are doing
something fun after the break.
Stick around. Come on back.
More with Olivia Rodrigo.